después de dos años y medio en el cargo
el presidente de perú martín vizcarra
renunció aceptando el voto del
parlamento para destituirlo
hoy día
viejo palacio gobierno
y como martín vizcarra
no voy a tomar ninguna acción legal hace
dos meses la oposición fracasó en un
primer intento de destitución de
vizcarra
esta vez el congreso peruano reunió
suficiente apoyo como todo por 105
congresistas
los congresistas acusan a vizcarra de
aceptar sobornos de empresas de
construcción cuando era gobernador
regional
los parlamentarios dignos de la
república el día de hoy han tomado el
psuv histórica pero los observadores
políticos señalan que la oposición
carece de pruebas los pocos aliados de
vizcarra en el parlamento dicen que su
desplazamiento es un movimiento
peligroso creemos que esto es una
decisión equivocada una decisión que
añade mucho más incertidumbre crea
problemas para estar seriamente a la
ciudad
la expulsión llega en un momento difícil
pero se enfrenta a una crisis económica
debido a la pandemia de kobe 19 tiene el
mayor número de muertes per cápita del
mundo los líderes de la oposición acusan
a vizcarra de haber manejado mal la
pandemia pero vizcarra sigue siendo
profundamente popular en su tiempo en el
cargo luchó duro contra la corrupción
incluso dentro de las filas de los
congresistas una política aprobada por
muchos votantes mientras que miles de
peruanos protestaron por su destitución